even if you haven't been told to
self-isolate in recent weeks you
probably know someone who has
so what's going on well it's largely due
to the rise in cases and the rollback of
lockdown
there are now over 32 000 cases a day
and they're doubling every 11 days or so
the government expects them to reach
50 000 a day by july the 19th and 100
000 a day in august
back of the envelope calculation
suggests there could be at least 2
million cases over the summer the third
wave
also means more of us are being
identified as close contact
that's people living in the same
household those who've been one metre
face to face from an infected person for
at least a minute
or fifteen minutes two meters away
statistics from nhs tests and trace
reveal a sharp rise in people being told
twice late since indoor mixing was
allowed in mid-may
reaching almost 184 000 people in
england
in the week to june the 23rd but
contacts are
also identified through the covert 19
app which has been downloaded by
nearly 26 million people the number of
people being pinged because they've been
in close contact with a positive case
has been rising since pubs and
restaurants opened for outdoor service
in
april accelerating when indoor mixing
was allowed in may
later statistics show just under 219
000 people in england received an alert
in the week to june the 23rd in all
almost 2.5 million have been pinged
since the app was released last
september
4.4 people for every positive case using
it
it has made a difference though data
shows 594 000 cases were prevented
in just the first three months of it
being used
now from august the 16th people who
have been double vaccinated won't have
to isolate
even if they've been in close contact
with someone that will help
some businesses struggling with staff
absences but perhaps
not pubs and restaurants sixty percent
of their staff
are aged 16 to 34 and are unlikely to
have had two doses by then
so just as they're allowed to open up to
more eager customers
they could still struggle to serve them